انتهت منصه نتفليكس من عرض الحلقات
الثلاثه الاخيره لوثائقي تدوق وذوقه ساسكس
هاري وميغان وحقيقه المشهد ما اختلف عن
اللي صار من بعد ما تم عرض اول ثلاث حلقات
فالجدل والانتقاد والغضب ما زال سيد
المشهد ولكن دوز الصدمات والمفاجات
والادعاءات والروايات في الحلقات هذه
الثلاثه الاخيره زاد كثير
يوهان
[موسيقى]
نور
ت فتره التعارف الثنائي والدعف الثنائي
ادعاءات عن التمييز العرقي لرامي
الخوف عليها من نفس المصير في الحلقات
الثلاثه الاخيره كملوا وكان في تركيز على
علاقه الامير هاري باخوه ولي العهد
البريطاني ويليام اللي قال انه
خلال اجتماع معين واتهم هاري العائله
المالكه بمحاوله الكذب لحمايه وكيف كان
القصر بيجنن الناس للنشر الاخبار السلبيه
عنه وعن زوجته وانه كل اللي عانوه من
العائله المالكه هو اللي خلاهم ياخذ
القرار ويختاروا انهم يبعدوا يعيشوا
حياتهم بحريه وسعاده على حد
الوثائق هذا عامل حاله جدل كبيره وطبعا
انتقادات وفجر موجه كبيره من الغضب بين
الناس اللي اعتبره وتعدي واضح وص على
الملك الراحل والعائله الملكه ككل وان
الهدف منه الكسب المالي وبالفعل في كثير
من الاخبار عن حصد الثنائي للكثير من
المكاسب الماديه مقابل الفيلم وارتفعت
المطالبات الشعبيه والرسميه بتجريد الامير
هاري وميجن من القابهم كذوق وذوقه ساسكس
ولكن لليوم ما في اي تعليق واضح وصريح من
القصر الملكي ولكن في شيء واحد لفت الناس
وعامل لهم صدمه انه في مصادر ملكيه قالت
انه على الرغم من كل اللي صار لكن ملك
تشارلز بيموت غصن الزيتون للامير هاري
وزوجته ولا زال ناوي يدعوهم لحضور مراسم
حفله نصيبه وكمان البلاد في السادس من
مايو وانه ما زال مرحب بذوق قصاص سكس في
القصر وعلى فكره هذه مو اول ولا هتكون اخر
مره الامير هاري وما يقلب الدنيا
بتصريحاتهم واخبارهم لسه كمان هيكون عندنا
ازمه جديده في يناير وهو موعد طرح كتاب
الامير هاري المثير للجدل اللي بيحمي
الاسم سبير او
في اشاره الى انه ابن ثاني للملك فهو مجرد
بديل في حال صار اي شيء لاخوه الاكبر
والمعلومات بتاكد انه في قلق وترصد للكتاب
لانه بيتضمن معلومات خاصه وانتقادات
للنظام الملكي وتفاصيل المكالمات بين
الامير وجدته الراحله الملكه اليزابيث
الثانيه قبل وفاه ابي فتره قصيره وحسب
التقارير الاعلاميه الامير هاري حصل على
مقدم بقيمه 20 مليون دولار جزء من صفقه ب
38 مليون دولار مقابل نشر المذكره
عن كل هذا الغضب فيه بريطانيا رسميا
وشعبيا تنضم الينا من لندن اللي هي
المحرره في صحيفه الشرق الاوسط اهلا فيك
معنا جوسيلين يعني دائما قاعده القصر
والعائله الملكيه البريطانيه انه لا تشتكي
لا تعلق او لا ترد على اي شيء
كسروا هذه القاعده اشتكوا ولكن القصر
مستمر في الصمت الى متى استمر القصر في
الصمت وهذه الادعاءات كل ما لها بتكبر
وتكبر
همم صحيح اللي قلتي ساره ولكن هالمره يعني
الشكوى كانت عالميه جدا وكانت مقابل مبلغ
مادي كبير جدا هذا بس اذا تكلمنا عن
السلسله اللي كانت من ست الحلقه يلا
حكيتها عنا بالمقدمه يلي قبض علي الامير
هاري وزوجته 100 مليون دولار هذا غير
الكتاب ولكن كمان الاستفاد منها شيء هو
همم
كمان ارباح لانه هذا الباقي رز همم اكثر
من 80 مليون مشاهد بالعالم وهذا اكثر مره
مشاهده هلا في قضيه القصر
لانه القضيه عم تكبر وصارت اكبر من قضيه
المعركه
همم اللي عم بيصير هلا هو اتهامات كبيره
كثير كثير ضخمه جدا غير مسبوقه يعني هي مش
اول مره بيكون في انتقادات بيكون في مشاكل
داخل القصر من ايام ليدينا باوائل
التسعينات وانهيار زواج من الاميره اصبح
اليوم ملك هيدا منها اول مره ولا راح تكون
اخر مره ولكن المساله التمييز العنصري
والاتهامات الكبيره اللي عم بتصير هلا همم
يعني حبينا او لا قل لنا ايه او لا بتاذي
بشكل كبير الى زازا الى صوره العائله
الملكيه بريطانيا عشان كده انا مستغربه
صراحه من صمت الكبير والكلام الان اللي
بيتم او بيقال يبدو انه
الارجنتين الارجنتين دخلوه هدف ضربه جزاء
واحد صفر ميسي ميسي داخل الهدف همم طيب
عشان لا انا عشان بس باوضح كمان الموضوع
عشان الصريخ اللي طلع ورائي انا مع مين
انا مو فارق عندي اليوم احد من الاثنين
يعني فا فا عادي اوكي انا انا قادر اعرف
من الصريخ تحديدا مين من زملائي اللي
بيصرخوا ورايا جوسيلين لهدرجه بس المهم
خلينا نرجع ليه موضوعنا انا كنت بقول لك
انه غريب جدا عدم تعليق الملك على الموضوع
لانه فعلا انت هم بيتهموا الان المؤسسه
ككل فهل طبيعي انه يرجع وبعدين يعزموهم
على حفله تتويج وانه لازال يقدر يتعامل مع
ك- ابن
همم بتاكد انا بافتكر انه راح يجوا راح
يحضر حفله تتويج مثل المسار لما توفي
حضروا ولكن حضور كان يعني غير محدد حتى من
افراد العائله يعني حضروا القصر همم بس بس
انتهت المراسم
انه راح يكون هالشي نفس الشيء خاصه مثل ما
انت ذكرت انه الملك تشارلز مش عم بيتخلى
عنهم
الفرصه انهن يرجعوا يمكن يفكروا بالموضوع
خاصه
نشرح بالدوم يعني المعلومات اللي عم
بيعطوها ااه ال ال القشره يعني عم بيبيعوا
قصص عائليه خاصه جدا وهي منا حي الله
عائله هذه عائله ملكيه عريقه من اهم
العائلات بالعالم
قصص العائليه الخاصه فيهم ولكن هالشيء هذا
مش راح يستمر يعني نحنا شفنا هل ست حلقات
وبلشنا همم
[موسيقى]
الان في حتى كميه يعني انتقادات اول حتى
كان مثلا في امريكا كان عندهم شعبيه اكبر
خلينا نقول من بريطانيا الان حتى في
امريكا في انتقادات كبيره لهم وفي تعليق
انه انتم كنتم تبغوا خصوصيه انتم قلت لكم
الحياه فيها حريه العائله المالكه مضت في
طريقها وانتم لازلتوا تعلقوا في نفس
الموضوع
بالفعل هيك يعني من ثلاثه ايام ااا تقريبا
صار في استطلاع للراي بي اميركا مثل ما
انت قلتي واتبين انه شعبيته انخفضت جدا
يعني الى الحديد وهلا هذا الشيء هذا انعكس
يجيبن على مين على خيو الامير
وزوجته الاميره كاثرين الاميرات ويلز يعني
كل شيء مش عم بيصب لمصلحتهن تمام التدخل
الرسم الوحيد كان من رئيس الحكومه
هناك لاول مره بيتدخل بهذا الموضوع
من العام المقبل راح بيكون في رقابه على
نتفليكس لانه لغايه هذه اللحظات ماشي على
نت فلكس يعني يحطه
اللي بدهم مثل المصاري مسلسل
[موسيقى]
دراما مستمره معانا نحنا بنشكرك كات مع
نجوى سيلين ايليا المحرره في صحيفه الشرق
الاوسط شكرا لك يا جوسيلين
[موسيقى]